remember that lie that came out
some days ago that border patrol
mounted on horseback were whipping
haitian immigrants
they were whipping them and we looked at
that on this show is being pushed by
basically the entire mainstream media
we were looking at that and said that's
not true
that's not true i guess you know i'm
really glad that right now big tech is
just focused on
spreading
public health propaganda because
if if they had been focused on spreading
immigration propaganda then they
probably would have taken us down for
observing the fact that the border
patrol agents were not using whips
against
the haitian illegal aliens
well it turns out that we were right and
the establishment media were wrong
and
they were not using whips and they were
not using chains and now even the
establishment media themselves are
admitting this here's jake tapper
calling out
a little little late for my liking but
jake tapper at least finally
acknowledging the truth and calling out
the health secretary or the the homeland
security secretary mayorkas
some of the initial descriptions of
those images were just patently false
there's now video out there that
provides more context uh having seen the
video uh are you certain that there was
actually wrongdoing
have you because there's now it would
seem it's pretty clear that actually the
initial reports that we were told were
not true we were going to play a clip of
brian stelter
who made this same point brian stelter
on cnn came out and he said you know the
initial reports they just weren't true
and actually they weren't using whip so
i had that i was i watched that clip
last night that clip has basically been
scrubbed from the internet by the time
that my editors today went to grab that
clip and put it into the show it was
gone
why was that was that because of cnn
didn't like it up there or maybe was it
because big tech didn't like it up there
very possibly very very possibly
knowing what they do knowing what they
do to this very show for spreading true
information wouldn't be surprised that
on the rare occasion that cnn says
something that's true
big tech would take that down but i
don't know all i know is it's gone but
ryan stelter did it too so i want to
give him credit if you're watching this
right now something tells me
you look at some stuff on the internet
that maybe you don't want people to know
about all right you use the little
incognito window and you make sure the
blinds are closed and then you type in
www.dailywire.com you type in all these
sort of things that are very politically
incorrect well protect your data with
expressvpn simple app it's for your
computer it's for your smartphone it
encrypts all of your network data
tunnels it through a secure vpn server
so that your internet service provider
cannot see any of your activity
think about all of your life that's on
the internet watch out about it okay i
do not go online now without expressvpn
on my phone on my computer just do it
very very simple
download the app one button check it out
today go to expressvpn.com
go to
expressvpn.com
michael that is e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
michael mich ael get three extra months
for free expressvpn.com
michael to learn more and protect your
data
now this is uh pretty funny that two
people on cnn would come out and and
call out the media for spreading and
stealth was doing this in particular he
said calling out the media for spreading
this misinformation that uh the border
patrol agents were using whips on the
haitian migrants because cnn was
spreading a ton of that misinformation
who was doing it chris cuomo
shared report reports of people being
beaten said the images smack of a bygone
era of slavery
no evidence that the even the border
patrol reigns touched anybody aaron
burnett also on cnn said quote video of
border patrol agents on horseback
confronting haitian migrants with whips
that was on september 21st on out front
just a complete lie also on cnn cnn's
white house correspondent john harwood
condemned quote those horrendous videos
of agents on horseback swinging lariats
or whips or whatever they are at least
john harwood is admitting he has no idea
what he's talking about by saying or
whatever or whatever but he mentions the
whips just a complete lie from the cnn
white house correspondent christian
amanpour who drew clavin refers to as
christian amapor journalist rightly so
interviews an activist who said that the
photos of the agents quote using reigns
as whips against migrants they were not
only startling and shocking but it's
triggering again
no evidence that that happened cnn
anchor laura jarrett misled viewers
about quote disturbing new video of
border patrol agents on horseback trying
to stop migrants from crossing the
border into the u.s look at that using
whips that was on early start on
september 21st complete lie jake tapper
himself actually
said he didn't quite go so far as to
mention the whips but he said border
patrol agents are aggressively
threatening migrants and aggressively
confronting haitian migrants i guess
i guess that could be true in the sense
that law enforcement is supposed to be
aggressive against criminals i guess
that's the point but he seems to be
framing it in such a way that's pretty
silly in a way that he's actually kind
of condemning now
and cnn's april ryan did the same thing
referring to the reigns or whips
whatever right again admitting she knows
nothing but still using whips so
i'm glad that cnn that tapper and
stelter are coming out and saying yeah
the media's got to stop stop this kind
of stuff
well before you accuse anyone else take
a look at yourself fellas because cnn is
the chief purveyor of that kind of fake
news i'm so glad that you enjoyed this
video on youtube i'm so glad youtube let
me keep this video up because sometimes
i say true things and then youtube
doesn't want me to say those true things
so they say that the true things are
false things and then they promote false
things and it's really frustrating if
you want to stop that kind of
preposterous dangerous anti-american
censorship i would strongly recommend
you go check out the audio version of
this podcast which is harder for the big
tech tyrants to censor you can get that
at the michael knowles show it's free
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your podcasts head
on over there before
some of these other joints try to censor
us entirely
[Music]